I'm Alan Guttmacher and
obstetrician/gynecologist I feel very
strongly that a man trained in modern
medicine cannot carry out the high
quality of performance because of the
restrictive decisions imposed by our
very archaic abortion laws and I feel
they must be changed I'm about to Frank
aid basic iotus I am opposed to any
liberalization of abortion laws
especially for psychiatric social and
economic indications my name is Richard
lamb by vocation I'm an attorney I add
vocation I'm a member of the Colorado
House of Representatives I was chief
sponsor two years ago with Colorado's
new liberalized abortion law and I will
act today as the moderator
you
[Music]
welcome to the exploration of concepts
and controversies in modern medicine one
of a series of programs dedicated to
examining the uncertain candidly
recognizing that much of today's
teaching is necessarily based upon
opinion and the opinions of eminent
physicians in a given field vary widely
the National Medical audio-visual Center
believes that openly airing such
opposing views is a basic responsibility
of medical communication the Honorable
Richard lamb state representative state
of Colorado will act as moderator of
this presentation I think one of the
problems dealing with the subject of
abortion and I think this is at least
one thing that we can all agree on is
the problem about in what category in
what term and what discipline should the
subject be discussed in some people say
this is a strictly medical problem other
people I've heard say it's strictly a
legal problem many people are beginning
to think it's perhaps a sociological
problem the public health problem
there are many disciplines which lay
claim to an interest in the subject of
abortion I think that there is an
agreement even among a lot of people
that it may be a little bit of all of
these disciplines but there again that
doesn't solve the problem because then
each profession continues to say well
it's more of my problem than it is of
those other disciplines without solving
that problem let me give you just a
brief summary of what happens in a state
that does liberalize its abortion law
Colorado liberalized their abortion law
by it was signed by the governor on
April 25th 1967 we are a state of two
and a half million people and there is
approximately 35,000 live births a year
in Colorado previous to the signature of
the new law there was approximately 50
abortion hospital abortions performed in
Colorado in a year
in the first nine months after the
passage of our law there was 140
abortions performed in Colorado Hospital
and in the calendar year 1968 there was
476 abortions performed the grounds of
these at that total 616 abortions the
grounds were about 55% under the mental
health provision of our law there was a
proximately 26% of these abortions were
performed on non residents of the state
of Colorado which generally is about
approximates the other medical care
being a state like Colorado drains a
great deal of western Kansas Eastern
Utah we have the abortions were
performed on generally on people that
make up a cross section of our community
one of the things that was seen was is
that the lower economic groups have now
had a lot more access to abortion than
they had ever had under the previous law
50% of the abortions were performed on
single women 40% were performed on
married women and 10% on divorce one now
the try to discuss what problems there
are in subject of abortion to try to
decide whether this is the right whether
this is the end product whether Colorado
experience is the end result or whether
or not it has gone too far or whether or
not we in effect have not gone far
enough we will have other panelists and
we will turn to dr. Guth laughs I think
that medical evidence realizes that
there are seven additional states out of
our 50 that have liberalized their laws
from my point of view not broadly enough
but nevertheless eight of our states out
of 50 now have more liberal laws the old
law of course in practically all states
was that abortion could be done purely
and simply and only to preserve
the life of the mother and from my point
of view that is much too restrictive you
must remember that when means laws were
framed medicine was a very different
thing most of the laws date from about
the 1820s and 30s at this time there was
no anesthesia
there was no antisepsis there was no
transfusion and carrying out an abortion
must have been a hideously painful and I
should think a dangerous procedure now
since then medicine has made magnificent
progress and abortion in hospital can be
performed with extraordinary safety I
know in my rich experience which goes
back in medicine in some 40 years I've
never seen a death after therapeutic
abortion and I think that it's fair to
say that it is one of the least
dangerous operations actually we have
excellent statistics from Czechoslovakia
from Hungary on a million consecutive
legal abortions and there were 25 deaths
that's 2.5 400,000 operations so I think
we can say that this is a very safe
operation now in addition to its safety
medicine now I think can pay much more
attention to the whole personality of
the individual we can relax because most
of our killers have disappeared
pneumonia
various infections and we can now become
more than just kind of carpenters I
think we can see the personalities
totality and from my point of view
abortion can contribute tremendously
through the happiness of the woman
involved and very often to the family
constellation to give his viewpoint on
the subject dr. aid well I think several
points have already been made which
warrant thorough discussion my first
point would be of course the
abortion means that a human life is
being taken now to declare about any
individuals right at any time from the
moment of conception is devoid of value
in my opinion is a judgement that no man
has the right to make and to end an
individual's life is murder committed
because it has been decided that he's no
longer a human being in need of help and
protection but merely an object whose
worth is measured according to whether
or not his continued existence or his
destruction is expedient for someone or
the nation as honorable lam has pointed
out whenever on abortion love is
liberalized there is an immediate and
significant increase in the number of
therapeutic abortions performed but I
think also what must be stressed but
regardless of how many legal abortions
are performed there's absolutely no
evidence but this in any way affects the
rate of illegal abortions furthermore
dr. Guttmacher has pointed out the
progress in medicine and quite properly
stressed the advances that had been made
which makes surgery in general much
safer than it used to be but I honestly
believe that also it must be stressed
that therapeutic abortion is as the
British Medical Journal just simply
pointed out on December 28 1968 in an
editorial it is not a simple operation
it does carry its hazards it's safety
depends on the surgeon performing the
operation and even the method of
termination that is employed admittedly
dr. bhoothnath was absolutely right when
he says that the mortality rate
associated with for a Pyrrhic abortion
is relatively low but the morbidity rate
depends on the skill of the surgeon
performing determination for pregnancy
and also on the method of termination
accurate statistics coming out of
England for example we're very fine
records are kept with indicate that the
morbidity rate
varies from one to five percent
depending primarily on the method of
termination used but I would point out
that you do have hemorrhage
we do have perforation of the room
sometimes requiring secondary
exploratory abdominal surgery as a
result so that it's not an innocuous
operation but also as a psychiatrist I
would stress one very very important
aspect of this problem technically it is
true we can empty the room of the baby
but we cannot squeak the idea of the
baby out of the mother's mind and
therefore there are going to be women
who while in the early stages of
pregnancy and being emotionally upset
would be inclined to destroy the infant
with inner womb subsequently although
the infant has been removed by whatever
termination method is used the idea of
having had a baby in her womb is still
in her mind and that's not easily
eradicated and subsequent feelings of
guilt and things of this sort are real
we psychiatrists see them and we have to
contend with them dick I don't know
whether I'm allowed to to question some
of the things frank said but rural
friends oh I think he won't mind in the
first place to him abortion is murder
I'm no murderer and I've done abortions
to me it's quite different than shooting
even a man in warfare to me these are
undifferentiated cells which have the
potential for being a human being but to
me this baby is not a human being until
born and I am not willing to let it go
that all doctors agree that this is
murder because I daresay of the group
listening to me or to us a certain
proportion perhaps I think the largest
number will think it's not murder so I
think you have to define this process
according to your own intellectual point
of view and perhaps your own social and
religious background
and in the second place I think that
there's a psychiatric sequelae of
abortion this can be challenged this is
doctor AIDS experience I dare say that
he has perhaps had patients who were
perhaps because of religious affiliation
will have more feelings of guilt than
perhaps most of listeners now we did a
study at Mount Sinai on our ward
patients who are largely at Porto Rican
and Marcus and peck published a study on
50 consecutive abortions done at Mount
Sinai therapeutically for psychiatric
indications we had one patient of the 50
who developed an acute psychosis about
three months posted boredom this lasted
about three months and apparently she
made a satisfactory Republic as far as
they could determine and perhaps their
study was not as profound as perhaps
proper aid would like it they could find
no evidence of psychiatric socratic so
that I think we hire there are areas of
disagreement this thing is not nearly so
easy to analyze as perhaps dr. ade and I
both make it I see it from one point of
view and dr. 82 from the Taizo from that
interview I would like to let a skew
both and what you would write into the
law if you were dealing what kind of law
would you propose to deal with the
problem of abortion well before I answer
your question sir I think that in order
to keep this dialogue going in a
meaningful way for the audience that I
should make two comments about what Alan
has said number one this study that he
referred to with only 50 patients I'd
have to have more data as a scientist
before I would accept or reject the
validity of the findings number two
although it is true I am a Roman
Catholic I'm not opposed to abortion
just on religious grounds
in fact the majority of the patients
that I'm called on to treat are not
Catholic and still I still see feelings
of guilt and so
work what he also raised I think one of
the crucial questions and that is is the
fetus a human thing now I admit that
many abortion supporters say that the
fetus is nothing more than a blob of
protoplasm nothing more than that but I
don't think that they honestly recognize
our own contradiction
now if the fetus is not a human being
what is it that's damaged in the early
weeks of its experience by a viral
infection such as rubella by drugs
chemicals x-rays and so forth which is
used to justify abortion if the fetus is
not a human being why are so many
physicians and scientists spending
millions of dollars and countless hours
trying to develop a vaccine for rubella
trying to devise ways of avoiding birth
defects trying to develop an artificial
placenta trying to fertilized ovum
outside the body from the test tube and
by artificial insemination and genetic
engineering and genetic surgery to
enable man to improve the mere and
remote descendant that he may have now
furthermore in this country if the fetus
is not a human being that I must ask the
question why does the United States Food
and Drug Administration caution against
or in some instances prohibit the
administration of certain drugs in the
first three months of pregnancy now I
can answer that because may I finish
please and then I thought you had to
know I have one other point that I'd
like to make and that is it to my mind
to say that a fetus is not human is
sheer nonsense
dr. Keith Walker was a fetus I was a
fetus you were a fetus if the our
existence began this way and for someone
to terminate if someone had turned it's
a single existence of any one of the
three of us we wouldn't be here on this
panel today so that the fetus is a human
thing I think it's semantics to say that
human life doesn't begin until
implantation or until the third month
with a six-month or until a baby born
what constitutes humane or humaneness
well I agree with you for once about
this I think that a sperm is a living
potential human being I think an egg is
a potential living human being I think
nothing that has changed by the process
of fertilization these we're living
cells before fertilization they become
continue to live after fertilization
what they are potential human beings
this is where you and I differ I think
that human life attention human life
begins at the moment of fertilization
it's actually preceded now what I think
is that you're not I was a fetus to be
sure but I was a potential human being
until I was born and that's where you
and I differ and no matter how much we
argue we're not coming to a common area
degree well I'll agree that it would be
very difficult to come to a common area
of agreement I will agree to the sperm
is a living cell and so to isn't over
what the genetic composition of a sperm
is different from the genetic
composition of the ovum and it isn't
until you have fertilization that you
now have a unique human being that never
existed before never exist again and
brought the ovum only contributed health
of a genetic or chromosomal makeup of
that the fertilized l2 no no it's not
true this parameter in each cell right
every farm has a different chromosomal
makeup precisely but it only has half of
any other cell in the body that's
granted but and so there's an ovum I
don't that when you have a new human
being every cell until they're
differentiated again into ovum or form
sperm has a complete chromosomal
complement not a half well I mean to say
that this arm is a potential human thing
I think genetically at least you're
completely erroneous and that it is
misleading to say this what a thought
you had to have a human being then
you'll grant that no because it can
become nothing but firm until it
actually fertilizes them over then you
had a new humanely we're not hitting
head you and I differ in the fact that I
think that a fetus is uber through the
potential you think
the fetus is actual the human being
immediately after fertilization so let's
agree on that and let's go on alright 5
losing a lot of valuable time I would
then be interested both doctors who at
your viewpoints on what should be the
indication of therapeutic abortion when
you're dealing in the realm of law and
that's that to me is the problem right
now because medical indications only
designate a certain stage of medical
learning at a certain point in history
and yet when you try to write these
things into law you have at least in
Colorado 100 legislatures only one of
whom is a doctor trying to decide what
is good medical practice and this is
very difficult I would like to ask you
what would you see to be a model
abortion law or dealing with the subject
well in dealing with the subject my
answer immediately would be but I live
in a pluralistic society I'm perfectly
willing to accept the law that is now on
the book which permits the portion to
save the life of the mother I frankly at
this moment deny that there are any
psychiatric indications that justify
liberalization of the abortion laws
after all psychiatry has made progress
just as surgery and medicine has made
and it would be a rare pregnant woman
psychiatrically ill who could not be
carried to term safely with the modern
psychiatric therapies that we have now
once you get out of the psychiatry and
the medical indications you're talking
in terms of social and economic
indication if we're going to have
abortions done for social and economic
reasons then items were into the very
dangerous waters and as a matter of fact
I confess that most of the so-called
psychiatric indication which have
justified up to 70% of the abortions
done in your state in fact in California
and even in the state of Maryland from
which I come have been done for alleged
psychiatric reasons their club reactive
depression until the laws were
liberalized I'll tell you we never had
so many reactive depression right now in
fact these are socio-economic
indications not
quickly speaking psychiatric indication
now what I also must stress is that the
evidence we already had from the United
States and from England is that the
minute you liberalize the abortion laws
women think that they are entitled that
they have a legal right to abortion on
demand and this puts pressure on the
position and I'll illustrate that
suppose the physician prescribes an oral
contraceptive or inserted into your
lying device and this woman becomes
pregnant now she comes back and accuses
intake you're responsible for this do
something about it these emotional
pressures are going to be to a port this
woman now also there's from something
that was unforeseen when the law were
liberalized in Colorado and in
California and in Maryland and that is
but we now have an unwritten workable
rule which goes it and doubt abort
because if one allows the pregnancy to
go one this may subsequently be used as
grounds for a malpractice suit against
the physician if I may go back from the
socio-economic and they'll take up the
other indication namely the question of
a suspected fetal abnormality this puts
a physician in a very difficult position
because he must now decide how many
normal he's going to sacrifice to
prevent the birth of one abnormal baby
now this is one reason why physicians in
general are not to in favor of abortion
they find a tree public and if you
actually check the figures in your state
and in California and in Maryland what
is coming out is that the majority of
the abortions are being done in a few
hospital by a relatively small number of
physicians the majority of obstetricians
gynecologist are not performing abortion
any more than they did before the law
was liberal i and great majority of them
are going then what would still be
considered valid medical indications
turn to dr. Goodman I think we must
liberalize laws because the current
situation is highly discriminatory both
in regard to legal and
illegal abortion in New York there are
five times as many therapeutic abortions
done on the private services of
hospitals on the click services
theoretically then the private patient
is five times as ill this is ridiculous
in the second place anybody knows that
$700 will buy a safe abortion Puerto
Rico and if you don't have $700 and you
only have five bucks your chance of
having a safe abortion is extraordinary
hideous we have a million illegal
abortions estimated in the United States
and what I want to see is to give poor
people people who don't have the money
in the influence a decent break and I
think we have to do this by liberalizing
our laws and spelling out for the time
being what are those indications quite
clearly now I agree that it boss sure
should be done for the preservation of
life or health mental or physical I
agree that abortion should be done in
cases of food sex crime I agree that
abortion should be done when there is
grave likelihood of the fetus being born
either malformed or [ __ ] furthermore
I think that any woman who has had four
living children should have the choice
as to whether or not another pregnancy
is gonna be an asset to the family
constellation who can make this judgment
better a doctor a lawyer a legislatures
no the woman herself is in the position
to make that decision I further feel
that any woman who's 40 years old should
have the choice of whether or not to
remain pregnant I agree with Plato in
his Republic who thought that anyone
would have 40 or more to be aborted and
by that time she certainly is mature
enough to make the proper decision I
think that any woman who is physically
or mentally incapable of caring for a
child should be aborted if she wishes it
and I think that any girl of 16 or less
was illegitimate ly pregnant should be
aborted she desires it because I can't
to you that they construct the
experience for either the girl or a
healthy environment for the child to be
born that's a good luck sir let me ask
you this do you think that the fact of
the statistics that were just presented
by dr. aid with regards to the large
number of abortions performed
the psychiatric ground you think number
one that this needs explanation and if
you do would you care to comment I know
I think it simply shows a sense of
humanity in the medical profession
we're not rigid psychiatrists we're not
saying a woman's going crazy because
he's not aborted
we're simply saying that this woman
doesn't have the emotional maturity of
emotional background to be a good parent
or we feel that this pregnancy is going
to be emotionally destructive on her
something it's not going to add to her
happiness or to her growth or to her
personality and therefore it can be
eliminated we're looking at psychiatry
not from the point of view of insanity
insanity or psychosis but looking at it
for a much more general point of view
what is the growth likelihood of the
personality due to the pregnancy that to
me is a much more important context you
have a rebuttal to that yes I would
simply say it right away we're putting
some people into the class of the case
the second class citizens and that if
someone is unone if this is
justification for terminating their
existence and that if someone is likely
to be a burden either on the mother or
on society that this is justification
for terminating their existence now my
feeling is that at that philosophy which
is in any life philosophy in my opinion
permeates the United States then the
weak and the dependent and the agent
have a lot to be afraid of because if
your existence is going to depend on
your quality and not only in violence of
your life
not when it's intrinsically determined
value but just on that judgment as to
whether or not you think you're going to
be a burden either to a mother or to
society and I think many many people in
the United States today but a start
worrying because they're in trouble I
don't think that follows logically told
but the language here let me ask you and
along the same line though we had
evidence before the Colorado Legislature
that all we were doing was bringing up
what was obviously and long existing
medical practice for instance in the
1960 issue of obstetrics and gynecology
there was a statement showing the
indications performed abortions were
performed in the
hundred and sixty-seven major hospitals
in the United States and
neuropsychiatric rubella all of these
reasons were already being performed and
so we thought all we were doing is
bringing up the law what medical
practice had been doing for years well
that doesn't necessarily make it right I
know this is exactly what you've done
and I have no question about the
sincerity of your motives at all but I
insist you say that we've got to decide
whether or not human life is sacred
because of human life isn't sake what
nothing else is we've got to decide
whether you larai or any other person in
this world has the right to decide who
shall live and who shall die I think on
that I see that we are getting a summary
I wonder if each of you would like to
give just a very short summary of your
positions again well I'm opposed to
abortion and I would stress that so far
in England and the United States
abortions has been done primarily for
soap cloud psychiatric indications on
young single girls you see who certainly
are not as social economically
classifiable as disadvantaged doctor
good luck I would say that the main
difference is that I have just as much
reverence for human life I believe as
anyone who opposes changes in the
abortion laws I want them changed
because I revere human life I wanted to
be strong and healthy and happy let me
say in summary that in dealing with the
problem at least from the point of the
legislature we have certain problems
number one is should abortion be
performed number two by who where and
with whose consent these are some of the
problems that to deal with in the
legislature as opposed to the medical
thank you we thank dr. Alan Guttmacher
dr. Frank Abe jr. and the Honorable
Richard lamb for their interesting
analysis of a critical problem in
patient care in subsequent programs we
shall continue to record equally
significant concepts and controversies
in modern medicine the opinions
expressed on this program do not
necessarily constitute endorsement by
the Department of Health Education and
Welfare the Public Health Service or its
constituent
[Music]
you
[Music]